it's no secret that being trained by
Abby Lee Miller is no piece of cake but
according to her previous dancers some
of Abby's teaching methods are simply
unforgivable even the sweet and talented
Mackenzie Ziegler has stopped talking to
her former dance coach and after hearing
why we can't say we really blame her we
don't know about you but we were totally
shocked when Abby and Kenzie both showed
up at Jojo C was sweet 16 keep watching
to find out what happened to say that
Abby Lee Miller and Mackenzie Ziegler
have history would be an understatement
but despite their current relationship
there wasn't always trouble in paradise
in fact some might even say that Kenzie
and her former dance teacher share a
very special bond it's clear that no
matter what these two will always
appreciate and respect each other which
is something to applaud Dance Moms began
airing on lifetime back in 2011 and
Mackenzie was only 6 years old when she
started filming for the reality TV show
Kenzie and her older sister Maddie
Ziegler spent six years of their lives
dancing it up on Dance Moms and they
were incredibly talented to say the
least
so it comes as no surprise that they
both caught Abby's attention and
adoration but Abby's love for the girls
didn't start in season one it started
much earlier than that in fact Abby
first started teaching Kenzie how to
dance when she was only two years old so
as far as we know they've got some
serious family vibes going on between
them and it's perfectly normal to bump
heads with those closest to us during
stressful periods in our lives and let's
face it there's nothing more stressful
and dramatic than being on the set of
Dance Moms
so let's cut these drama queen some
slack we only know what Dance Moms wants
us to know and that's sort of the
problem when we were first introduced to
Melissa and the Ziegler sisters we were
under the impression that they didn't
know Abby all that much these are my two
daughters Maddie and Mackenzie didn't
reality the Ziegler's and the Millers go
way back
Kurt Ziegler and Abby Lee Miller were
friends from high school Kurt made the
decision to divorce Melissa in 2011 when
Dance Moms first aired he claimed that
his wife's hectic dance schedule was
tumultuous in their relationship and
since he and Abby were still friends
this no doubt impacted her relationship
with Melissa so it's safe to say that
everyone the
children included had a lot on their
minds to top it all off melissa was
working at Abby's studio to help pay her
kids tuition which just added fuel to
the fire
Abby who was more of an aunt figure than
a dance teacher always favored Maddie
over her other dancers which hurt
Melissa and Kenzie's feelings so after
six long years of filming the popular
show Melissa and her girls chose to call
it quits fans have speculated why the
Ziegler's severed ties with Abby but the
truth is there is no one reason but
rather a collection of instances that
caused their once strong relationship to
waver Dance Moms fans will never forget
season six episode 15 which is when
Melissa announced that she was leaving
the Abby Lee dance company and taking
both her girls with her this came as a
total shock but no one was more
surprised than Mackenzie who had no idea
what her mother had been planing she was
obviously hurt by the news after all the
ALDC was all she knew and she'd be
leaving her best friends behind all of
the girls friends but it didn't take
long for the Ziegler sisters to realize
that their mother had made a calculated
move
Melissa broke the news to the world on
April 12 2016 and just three months
later Abby would plead guilty to felony
bankruptcy fraud and soon serve a
one-year sentence in federal prison
although she was released early her
sentence confirmed what some Dance Moms
fans already knew something suspicious
was going on behind the scenes the
Ziegler's chose to keep their distance
while Abby Lee was being scrutinized by
the courts which led to Mackenzie cut in
contact with Abby but if there's one
thing that helps Mackenzie make her
decision it's how Abby Lee's influence
negatively impacted her musical career
but more on that later
when we hear the word fighter we
automatically think of Abby Lee Miller
sorry about that Christina Aguilera the
renowned dance coach has never been one
to stand down when the going gets rough
which is why it comes as no surprise
that season 8 of Dance Moms is set to
air on June 20 19 you would think that
eight months in jail and a non-hodgkins
lymphoma cancer diagnosis would prevent
Abby from saving grace but that's just
not her style
Abby's health issues caused her former
dance students to reach out and send
their love and support The Dance Moms
fans couldn't help but notice that the
Ziegler
weren't at the front line both Maddie
and Mackenzie gave their support from
afar and only had good things to say
about their former dance coach during an
interview with Us Weekly Mackenzie was
asked if she and Miller still keep in
touch and the dancer said not really but
I wish her the best and she's awesome
however prior to this statement
Mackenzie interviewed with dance backs
and revealed that sometimes I wish I was
never on that show because of how much
stress and drama
Abby inflicted upon her here in these
sorts of things is probably what causes
Abby to lash out in anger
so despite saying kind words about
Mackenzie from time to time Abby didn't
hesitate to ridicule her Dancing with
the Stars contemporary performance on
Instagram although we weren't surprised
by Abby's actions Kenzie was only 14
years old at the time and picking on
young teens isn't a nice thing to do if
you help someone accomplish something
great it's customary for you to tell
them that you're proud of them however
this just isn't Abby Lee Miller's Forte
instead of praising the Ziegler sisters
for their obvious talents and unbeatable
dedication
Abby chooses to say that they owe her
their success and let's not get things
twisted it's obvious that without the
ALDC the Ziegler sisters wouldn't have
their big breaks but that doesn't take
away from how hard they worked to get on
top so after hearing Abby take credit
for their success time and time again
it's only normal that Mackenzie chose to
sever ties with Abby during The Dance
Moms Abby Lee tells all special the
dance coach revealed that she was
disappointed over the fact that she
wasn't able to share in the Ziegler
sisters post show success she went on to
say that she confidently believes that
the sisters wouldn't be where they are
today if it weren't for her before
finishing her statement Abby also said
that there were more good times and bad
times I hope that she doesn't forget the
good times by now we all know that Abby
favoured Maddie over everyone else which
led her to compare everyone to her
number one people
Kenzie included so we're not so
surprised that Kenzie is keeping her
distance and feeling happier than ever
we previously mentioned that Abby Lee
Miller is basically Mackenzie in
Maddie's aunt and who wants their pesky
aunts commenting on their social media
posts no one that's who
Mackenzie made the decision to block
Abby on Instagram in 2017 and
was completely shocked when she found
out while posting a throwback pic of the
girls on Instagram Abbi realized that
she couldn't tag Mackenzie in the
picture and totally freaked
she'd been blocked but when you think
about it it was a long time coming
Abby Lee's comments get a lot of views
and she's not one to leave happy and
supportive posts and seeing as Mackenzie
is growing up and trying to be her own
person the last thing she needs is for
Abby to ridicule her online whether
Melissa had a hand in this is up for
debate but for the most part it looks
like then twelve-year-old Kenzie wanted
to break free from Abby's chains
although it might seem childish blocking
someone on Instagram is a pretty big
deal especially when you've known them
for your entire life
but then again receiving antagonizing
comments from someone who wants to
caused you a lot of stress and
insecurity isn't exactly optimal sorry I
believe you've been shunned nothing will
break up a lifelong friendship and
mentorship like a good old-fashioned
lawsuit yes we're talking about
Mackenzie's musical battle against kiss
Smith music and it's frontman Andrew
Logan it's no secret that Kenzie is a
talented singer who aspires to become a
popular artist and she's well on her way
but unfortunately Abby Lee Miller's
guidance sort of put a damper on
Kenzie's rise to fame in 2017 Mackenzie
Ziegler was sued by KISS Smith music for
allegedly breaking her contracts by
working with another producer
however the Ziegler's fired back with a
lawsuit of their own stating that they
were strong-armed by Abby Lee Miller
into signing the contract according to
Melissa the only reason Mackenzie signed
the contract was that Abby convinced
them that Andrew Logan was the real deal
however her promises fell flat and Logan
seriously underpaid the team for her
music so where was Abby during this
lawsuit well she was in jail minding her
own business so it's easy to see why the
Ziegler's have little sympathy for Abby
during her time behind bars because well
she was still causing them problems
despite being in a Cell you can run but
you can't hide from Abby Lee Miller
we're looking at you Mackenzie Ziegler
how many of you remember the vaping
incident of 2018 well we for one have
yet to forget about it they beam is an
addictive pastime that isn't recommended
for teens so we totally
I agree that Mackenzie shouldn't have
been vaping on camera in front of her
many fans however Mackenzie did go on to
say that she wasn't actually vaping she
was using a Mong which is a water vapor
mixed with essential oils Mackenzie was
only 13 years old at the time and simply
pulling a little stunt on her fans yet
somehow Abby Lee Miller managed to
comment on the post and keep in mind
that Abby was actually in jail at this
point Mackenzie has her own clothing
line with justice
so Abby attempted to tag the clothing
brand saying do you sell vapes now this
shade didn't go unnoticed and Kenzie
fans quickly defended the dancer they
were quick to point out that someone who
is in jail shouldn't be giving anyone
advice still the sort of comment is
something teenagers should expect from
older figures who care about their
health but at this point Kenzie just
doesn't want Abby's opinions whatsoever
hence why she blocked her in the first
place the adorable Jojo Co has a very
different relationship with Abby Lee
Miller then the Ziegler sisters do so we
weren't surprised that Abby Lee Miller
received an invitation to JoJo's sweet
16 birthday bash the party took place in
April 2019 at the W Hollywood in Los
Angeles
Jojo chose to throw her birthday party
in April instead of May which is when
her actual birthday takes place fans
weren't shocked when Abby Lee made her
grand appearance however they were sort
of surprised to find out that Mackenzie
Ziegler was also in attendance since
Abby and Kenzie aren't on speaking terms
we couldn't believe our eyes both
parties kept things cool throughout the
evening
so despite not keeping in contact it's
clear that Kenzie and Abby aren't
supposed to seen each other if need be
this is super mature of them especially
since refusing to show up to JoJo's
party would only hurt Jojo in the end so
does this mean that Kenzie might one day
forgive her former dance coach or put
herself in a scenario where she's forced
to have a conversation with her only
time will tell
ever since Mackenzie left Dance Moms her
success has skyrocketed she seems
happier healthier and more comfortable
in her own skin
she wrote a self-help book titled
Kenzie's rules for life designed a
fashion line with justice and released
some pretty awesome music videos things
are going great for Kenzie who's turning
15
June 4th 2019 which is coincidentally
the premiere date for Dance Moms season
8 the world is her oyster and she'll be
damned if Abby Lee Miller gets in her
way although we can't deny that Abby has
helped Kenzie in her path to stardom
Kenzie is moving on with her life and
becoming her own person she's still
young and has time to form new opinions
so it's possible that she will one day
rekindle her relationship with Abby Lee
Miller that is if Abby is willing to
treat her as an equal and not a student
do you guys think Abby and Kenzie will
be friends again
or did that ship sail a long time ago
let us know in the comment section down
below give this video a big thumbs up if
you love Dance Moms and be sure to hit
that subscribe button for more videos
like this one thanks for watching the
things we'll see you soon
[Music]